you know mr. Roca yes sir I don't think
any game was long enough I crazily agree
with you I gotta find out what was
everything that was cut from n Games
final battle from this video from Screen
Rant I literally had a bunch of videos
John which videos do you want to cover
and then he's like no John Rocker go
check out his YouTube channel as soon as
you can link a description box and pin
comment telling about your channel John
it's a channel it's got all kinds of
stuff on their trailer reactions reviews
live streams mornings with the outlaw
got a geek buddies show got a wrestling
show called strong style got a sports
show coming up coming called game time
so I'm doing all kinds of things it's
all covered there a new outlet there the
outlaw nation come do it
come join the nation I would just
suggest quit being lazy
[Music]
oh yeah Avengers hey guys this is the
movie event of the decade fans waited
over 10 years to see the culmination of
the infinity saga and they were not
disappointed with the concluding chapter
true it's like five people who were
surprisingly slow in the opening
chapters but ramped up in intensity
culminating in one epic battle sure when
the Oscar into those three hours it was
quite a bit that was cut specifically
from the jaw-dropping crowd-pleasing
final battle between every single MCU
hero and the hordes of n that's awesome
that's if we not get ya
sneaking if they knows let's start
things off with him for most of his
screen time in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was just an angry purple alien
sitting on a throne barking orders in
all honesty Christian is only you to
bring a think of him and Stannis like
that [ __ ] deranged I was so mad when a
bunch more but there was more to Thanos
that was caught during endgame
tell me ya Wong we wanted to offer some
gruesome imagery we totally understand
why this one was left on the cutting
room really wasn't between the Avengers
and Team Panos things are fairly
straightforward the stano's from 2014 is
brought to 2023 to make sure his
original plan doesn't get undone as the
pentose from the past learned that his
future self was axed off and the Earth's
Mightiest Heroes seek to undo an
original tender taking a long time to
build
Universal genocide Santos is imposing
and a force to be reckoned with but in
his original pitch version of an
encounter with the Avengers things would
have been way more harrowing the pitch
saw 2014 Thanos finding Avengers in his
2014 timeline and utterly destroy them
all the world war making his jump into
the future to face them again Oh what
makes sense he's to face with the team
that logged off the original - is melon
at the beginning of endgame he kindly
returned the face Oh
tossing the head of Captain America onto
the battlefield before the event using
fear as a tactic to illustrate that he's
already beaten them and that he's about
Wow
oh damn it awesome we had most of the
script working except for the third act
because Anthony and I were clinging to
this concept that we wanted then it was
to walk up to the Avengers and throw
Captain America's head on the glass oh
it wasn't just the Russo's that seemed
to be obsessed with the idea of stalls
and heggs when coming up with imagery
for Panos Kevin Feige himself was toying
with the idea of Thanos operating from a
throne of skulls and bones and shadows
would lob caps head like a bowling ball
towards the Avengers from his heavy
metal inspired throne that would put the
one from Game of Thrones to shame not
exactly the best imagery for a pg-13
blockbuster concluding chapter seems
that logistics and storytelling and
getting Thanos from A to B was more of a
concern in this account than the imagery
itself as the team felt a bear yeah it's
gotta say that having the Avengers go
into a ship to see the throne no way
does that would improve concepts were
scrapped in favor of Thanos and ship
simply landing and Thanos getting
straight to business
regardless the scene was never shot
leaving us only to imagine what a
hardcore Thanos would have been like
all of the final battle and endgame is
on the ground with Thor cap and iron and
having a more intimate duel within that
Titan before literally everyone gets
involved once the snap is undone and
emerges on the battlefield through the
magic portals as mentioned most of this
battle is on the ground with Iron Man
rescue and warmish licorice shown
alongside some ravager ships and Pegasus
from new Asgard
yes quick shots but there was something
that was cut from the sky in this
instance and that was crank lands big
moment [ __ ] yeah
he missed cutscene crackling fights an
aerial battle that was actually shot but
cut from the final sequence fans will be
happy to know that cracklin has a
similar metallic mohawk to yondu's
hahaha lethal arrow with him too
sadly he didn't get to use it in this
particular sequence as he was too busy
flying about in a Ravager ship scene as
the scene relies heavily on green-screen
we don't have to know who crag wing
would be sharing the sky with but we can
assume that this bit would have likely
involved the Ravagers teaming up with
the wakandan airships to fight the
airborne Chitauri give us ladies oh my
god the first time the aerial battle
with ships and one minor character was
understandably cut justice for crackling
anyone yeah this was a moment that got
slashed from the climactic battle in
endgame
this was the scene that brought all the
heroes from all franchises together and
as such we got some pretty awesome and
unlikely team up during the epic battle
one such moment was unfortunately left
out of the movie and that moment
involved a team-up between a co a from
Black Panther and Valkyrie from Thor
while all the ladies of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe did get their moment
to shine together
Ocoee and Valkyrie actually had a scene
featuring just the two of them rot
unused content Oh was intended to swap
their respective weapons with each other
allowing an Asgardian to fight with him
a Condon weapon and vice versa Oh moment
but in the midst of a ton of fanservice
and epic wins it likely had to be shaved
out of the movie as it was already
pushing three hours in length and the
film already included a weapon swapping
scene when Kat began to use melee care
swap scene would have paled in
comparison
I disagree man listen I think everyone
should have swamp weapon yeah
a decade there was some stuff centered
around that whole entire bit that didn't
make the final cut of the movie there's
unused concept art for endgame that
shows a reluctant and uncertain Steve
Rogers attempting to lift the house
while the artwork looks like Steve is
reaching for the hammer the artist for
that specific piece
Ryan miner ding stated that he wanted
cap to feel uncertainty about whether or
not he could actually be worthy of
lifting up the hammer from the ground
rather than it flying straight into his
head as you all remember the Mjolnir gag
was set up all the way back in age of
Ultron right half attempted to lift a
hammer from the table resulting in these
smudges this scene but we think that the
final result in endgame was more
surprising and satisfied yeah so we
never final battle was awesome and was
immensely crowd-pleasing but it was
already pretty long which is why there
are so many cuts to the action sequences
whatever I'll see know that I would have
made the scene even longer but likely
would have felt more like padding as
opposed to offering anything of real
substance but preparing for the next
move the scene in question was said to
be around three minutes in life it
likely broke the flow of the action
there why it was scrapped from the movie
in favor of keeping the momentum going
and that's coming from the writers of
the movie themselves Chris Marcus and
sfera McFeely the pair thought that
breaking up the action for a quote fake
and fraudulent scene end quote with no
natural dialogue felt so weak that they
didn't even believe the scene with me
wow he really insulted your weak sauce
this next scene was cut as it was
ultimately redundant despite being
visually awesome after declaring for the
final time that he is Iron Men and
sacrifices himself for the universe Tony
dies
the Avenger is no matter from what
corner of the world all taken me as
they've the same yeah pretty cool but
Gamora who is the 2014 version of the
right why would she take a familiar with
who Tony is the Russos ultimately cut
the scene as they thought it took some
of the Thunder away from the upcoming
edit one thing this 2014 Gomorrah is
100% alive and well a fact that we
assumed but didn't get any clear answers
by the end of the movie one of the
people at the funeral see who was
naturally Morgan Stark daughter of Tony
and pepper Morgan was a surprise
addition to the narrative his endgame
jumps the narrative five years into the
future and Tony has settled into a
domestic lifestyle with a family but
while Morgan was played by Lexie rape
she wasn't the only actress set to play
Morgan in endgame right yeah 13 reasons
why was also brought on to play an older
version of Morgan after Tony snap his
fingers wearing the gauntlet moment much
like how a nose saw Gomorrah after his
own snap in infinity war the Russos
decide that audiences don't know Morgan
that well yet and breaking away from the
action to spend time with a minor
character may have been nice for Tony
but may have taken the audience out of
the film a bit to see a new version of
Morgan appear so suddenly instead of
having a deep moment weeds very likely
been hampering oh this person is at
first which would have taken away from
the scene and Rob because like he knew
he says I love you 3,000 that has been
the thing everyone's been saying ever
since and she's connected to that I'm
seeing an older version of hurt having
though that kind of thing is that per se
to him was it worth it rain can be a
great goodbye moments know which in
father and daughter very passionate
personal many together I think they say
kept all the like five-second scenes
okay yeah not the three minutes that
would have definitely mess with the flow
yeah awesome stuff Screen Rant love it
that was great I guess there were no
Monda
the Morgan seen like an older version of
Morgan but I kind of agree in the sense
you would still have to do like an
accustomed readjusting to older version
of Morgan and I think it's still
powerful and impactful it's I think it's
powerful enough that he leaves that
hologram video message behind for the
funeral I think that is the scene that
made the I Love You 3000 moment hit home
a lot of hard a good point yeah like I'd
rather have that scene in them in the
movie where she's singing where he's
saying goodbye to her when she's a
little girl through the hologram right
as opposed to saying goodbye to her when
she's older in this metaphysical world
that's similar to like Fano sangamore
and infinity war this is my personal
opinion no I think it's a good point
actually I hadn't thought of that how
much better that scene is and it's a
great way for him to say goodbye on his
terms without any kind of weird
creepiness of being in another realm
yeah it's showing an older Morgan makes
it seem like oh you're gonna miss all
these years with me as I grow up that
was a better way to do and left the
audience feeling better but let's talk
about this head rolling that would have
been awesome the stakes could have been
a little bit middling here no explain
what I mean yeah one side of me goes if
he shows up with a head rolling cap that
increases the stakes of this 2014 Thanos
showing how much of a lethal threat he
is true but I think as an audience
viewer I remember the first time I
watched it going they could kill off cap
in this movie they might kill off Kappa
like as I think a lot of us would agree
that when Kappas that beautiful like
painting shot where he's watching Thanos
and the whole army coming his when he's
standing alone with his shield yeah it's
this really harrowing moment and none of
us and the first time watching it we're
thinking oh this is probably what all
the other people are gonna show like
work so well is because we weren't
thinking about that I feel like we might
have been on the lookout for it because
you already got the head rolling moment
of them trying to raise the stakes so I
think that might have at least for me as
an audience member I would have been
aware that they were trying to raise the
threat level Mike well they already kill
off that 2014 version of cap they're not
gonna call this version of cap right in
this same movie now - you know that's
just my belief but same time I think
would've been cool good movie
more you're not cutting the head off
Captain America I have the America
they're not doing it nurse it's weird
with movies and chess is like their
television shows i watch ya our network
television that do these like very
violent things and I'm like this is
supposed to technically fall under pg-13
but it's so violent yeah on TV but then
I think about like Disney pg-13 they
probably wouldn't be able to get away
with something that gory
I mean there's that scene in Apocalypse
Now when he drops Fredrik forces hand up
in Martin Sheen's lap Brando does it's a
pretty harrowing moment so you put that
in and gay there's enough already
oh there are six hours of both those
movies and throwing in the hand of
Captain America as a bowling ball in
front of these guys is insane so I think
that would have been just maybe a step
too far so I'm glad they got pulled back
but I love the fact that flag you had a
sensibility to do it yeah I'll let you
know that a horror movie in the und MCU
is not out of the realm of possibility
down the road now like cuz he was
talking about the fan especially have
him lose like a skull yeah yeah sit on a
throne of skulls yeah that would have
been neat the weapons swap with Valkyrie
Nicoya I would have been badass that
would have been awesome I agree I might
have been a little redundant to a
certain extent because you did get that
moment with cap and the work I feel like
you could have done something else
though with them they didn't have to be
a weapon swap yeah it would've been cool
it just even team up and the weapon swap
didn't have to be like hey let me toss
this it could be the one weapon got
knocked out the other one got knocked
out they grabbed them most of them and
then they use it then tossed it back to
each other he didn't have to be a weapon
swap like what you saw with Thor and
Captain America would have been more in
the flow of the bathroom right there was
a way they could have done it which
would have been badass but just the idea
of Valkyrie yeah yeah you know an
Asgardian using wakandan weaponry and
vice versa would have been awesome what
do you think about cracklin scene being
cut I think it's a shame but cracklin is
not like I don't think that that's the
moment that you announce Kremlin's taken
over the Ravagers and he is now the new
yong yeah it would have been lost
amongst all the others moments that were
going on in the battle I think you saved
that for a guardians of galaxy vol 3
because I still think we need a we still
need to earn a little bit more with that
makes like yeah like Sean Gunn yeah we
do of course we like him but I don't
feel like he's anywhere near as the
level of beloved as any of the ensemble
in the guard at the galaxy we right so I
feel like it would have been like a neat
moment but I don't think it would have
been
rewarding for most people yeah you're
right like in Guardians 3 they should
really use that to their advantage to
build up the crackling characters to
make him a lot more beloved yeah and
nothing says they can't have a flashback
scene where Craigslist says I was there
too nobody got along with it would it be
really funny yeah I shoot it anyway
happened so I could still be in there
some way down the road actually would be
really is going on to handle that kind
of moment really well what was this
three-minute conversation now I'm like I
asked - um yeah balancing like that
stool and battle scenes are great when
they're choreographed and they have
moments to have conversations those
conversations most of the time are
usually brief yeah because you takes you
right out of a battle scene when you
spend too much time talking he'll leave
in 1917 those battle scenes are right on
top of each other they don't spend a lot
of time having conversations the best
scenes in the battle that are just
scenes are short-lived but they're more
visual yeah like when Tony finds Peter
Parker right he's rambling for a bit he
just hugs him like that is rewarding and
very touching but a three-minute
conversation is that that would slow it
back I mean I what's three minutes I
have a three and a half hour movie but
it's still it's still like yeah it would
have messed with the flow and the
kneeling scene we've talked about in
this channel I'm sure he talked about it
other places yeah that's cool I I like
the scene I do think though that if you
had the kneel moment and then you had
the funeral moment normally there's a
little too much right yeah it would have
been overdoing it don't dis what have
been overkill but as it stands
half of these I'm cool with hunting out
and there's other parts I'm like you
could tinker with that a little bit
better you're right that was fun now
it's fun it's cool enough it's cool
stuff then um you know yes America's
head on a pike guys subscribe if you
haven't done so already make sure check
out John Roca says the outlaw nation
channel do it as soon as you can
subscribe in real reagent-x click that
notification bell last but not least
Daniel gala Connor wrote you a poem
buddy Greg poem great poem time his name
is Daniel a masculine angel who saves
the sexy damsels
his name means God is my judge but the
man never holds a grudge even when I
steal a bite of his fudge
a handsome gentleman from the land of
Scotland when he joined our patreon my
positive emotions certainly heightened
last name Gallagher meaning valorous
Victor never one to bicker compare his
junk to mine it's certainly much thicker
overall bigger he achieved this there
being a pharmacist prescribed himself a
pill and through God's will he named his
little Daniel fill the word of the Lord
thanks be to God